so apparently Instagram influencers are
flocking to Chernobyl to take half-naked
Instagram selfies you know and the
producers up because of the because of
the show Chernobyl and so it's it's a
trendy thing now so you go to the
radioactive site and you take off your
clothing you take pictures
the producers up chernobyl are
encouraging everyone to stop doing that
which is very nice of them but I think
that um you know stop taking half naked
selfies at the site of a nuclear
meltdown is the kind of advice that you
should never give because the sorts of
people who need to hear it are probably
the sorts of people who'd need to learn
it the hard way I mean that's just
that's just me they might be a little
bit cruel but that's just that's my
opinion but yes I rule that probably is
best
really just to stay away from Chernobyl
in general I mean don't don't go there
naked yeah but I wouldn't even go there
fully clothed personally all right um a
bunch of stuff to get to today we'll
start with this from Fox News reading
from article and Fox News it says
representative Ilhan Omar has accused
the Trump administration of being
bigoted well this is new already as
someone accused the Trump administration
of being bigoted Ilhan Omar accuses I
mean this is a this is you don't hear
this every day do you this is a surprise
this time around their bigoted because
US embassies have had requests to fly
the rainbow flag denied
June is Pride Month promoting visibility
for the LGBTQ community blah blah blah
US embassies in Israel Germany Brazil
and Latvia made requests to the truck
ministration to fly the flag on the
official this is the important part on
the official embassy flagpole in honor
of pride but those requests have been
denied by the State Department
Omar tweeted this is another blatant
example of this administration's bigotry
and discrimination against the lgbtqia+
community this month President Trump
tweeted about Pride Month and during
Barack Obama's presidency there was
blanket permission issued to fly the
pride flag throughout the
month of June presumably on the official
embassy flagpoles
but this time around that's not the case
vice president Mike Pence who has
frequently expressed his opposition to
gay rights throughout his political
career said he supported the decision
not to fly the pride flag
he said I'm aware that the State
Department indicated that on the
flagpole of our American embassies one
flag should fly and that's the American
flag and I support that all right
and Omar of course is not the only maybe
you've heard about this controversy Omar
is not the only leftist to accuse the
Trump administration of bigotry for
their policy of not flying the pride
flag on the official embassy flag poles
and they're all you know they're all
saying kind of the same thing blaming it
on pence as always claiming that the
White House has banned pride flags at
embassies which is just not true that's
that's a lie the the trouble
ministration has not banned pride flags
now personally I wouldn't mind if they
did because I don't think a pride flag
has any business being anywhere anywhere
in or on an American Embassy because
that's not what an American Embassy is
supposed to be about but that's actually
not what happened - they didn't ban
pride flags they just said you can't fly
them under the American flag as like a
secondary flag on the on the official
flagpole of the embassy if you want to
have your pipe pride flag you put it
anywhere else you probably put it on the
side of the building if you want to but
you just can't put it on the official
embassy flag poles why is that because
embassies are primarily there to
represent America not to represent
homosexuality that's not the point of an
embassy we don't we don't it's it's not
our practice it has not been our
practice to set up embassies for sexual
orientations right that'll be a little
bit weird to have like a gay Embassy
somewhere I mean I wouldn't put it I
wouldn't be surprised if the next
democratic administration whenever that
happens to occur were to adopt a policy
like that but
as it stands right now we have embassies
for the country for the entire country
not just for gay people and the American
flag here's the thing about the American
flag for any LGBT persons as I'm um I'm
being excluded because you're not
putting the pride flag up no the
American flag represents all Americans
including gay Americans so if you're an
American and you're gay then you're
represented by the flag - by the
American flag every American is you
don't need nor should you get your own
flag on the pole at an embassy you are
under the same flag just like the rest
of us you should be happy with that but
this I think seems to be the theme of
the week I think every show I've done
this week that's why I'm ending with
this with this topic because I think
this has been the theme of leftist
whether we're talking about people you
know LGBT people or feminists or
whatever leftist claim they want equal
treatment but really what they're
advocating for is special treatment and
this is yet another example of that I
think it's a pretty a pretty profound
example of that where you have LGBT
people demanding their own flag on the
pole and an embassy under the American
flag I mean it's it's absurd that this
would that this conversation even needs
to be had that any embassy would would
would even request such a thing is
completely ridiculous that's not what
the embassy is supposed to be doing now
we should also
that the Trump administration this is
this is a blank again this is equal to
some blanket policy it's not like they
say oh yeah well we're not gonna put the
pride flag there on the on the pole
under the American flag but you know you
could put whatever you could put another
random flag up if you want you know you
could put a flag up celebrating st.
Patrick's Day if you want but you just
don't put the pride flag no that's not
that what the policy with the Trump
administration which is a consistent
policy it applies to everybody it also
pays due respect to the flag the policy
is you don't put anything under you
don't put any additional flag on that
boat that's a pole for the American flag
and that's it
nothing else goes on it but what the
LGBT people are saying so yeah I know
that's the policy but we should be an
accept our flag is different we're
different we're special no you're not
you're not special you're just like the
rest of us isn't that what you say you
want isn't that your claim that you want
to be treated just like everybody else
well you're getting it you know this is
what it's like to be just a normal
American we don't get our own special
flags
I don't have one special treatment not
equal treatment we should always keep
that in mind every time you hear a
leftist talk about equal treatment
that's not what they mean the word the
word equal has been substituted for
special because what you'll find in
pretty much every case is that if they
actually get equal treatment they
complain so this is just another
ridiculous controversy all right so
there's this new HBO show out that I
wanted to mention the daily wire has a
report about this show it says HBO and
its constant quest to jettison
traditional norms of dignity is
presenting a new series aimed at teens
that features graphic nudity and a
former Disney child star who wants to be
taken seriously as an actress euphoria
is the name of the show starring zendaya
who first
came to prominence of Disney Channels
show shake it up and it features an
actor using a prosthetic penis to commit
a rape as well as a scene in which
roughly 30 young men are shown fully
nude there's a sex scene between teens
involving choking and and even even a
charming scene where an obese man on a
webcam masturbates to a young woman this
is all in the show ok
euphoria creator Sam Levinson who wrote
the series based on his own experiences
with drug addiction boasted there are
going to be parents who are going to be
totally effing freaked out and and
that's what he's bragging about is that
parents are gonna be disturbed by the
show and I only mentioned this yeah I
hesitate to mention it because of course
what you have are these Hollywood
producers and and these HBO shows that
you know they can't get your attention
with a good story a good plotline good
acting a good script you know that
leaves your attention that way they're
just desperately trying to get your
attention by all the graphic grotesque
stuff that I just mentioned and so I
hesitate to actually give them the
attention that they're seeking because
that's what all this is just a just
attention seeking of course there's
there's simply no reason it's gratuitous
there's no reason to have stuff like
that in a in a show or a movie there's
no reason for doesn't advance the plot
and I'm not saying that every show or
movie should avoid topics like sex and
other different no you shouldn't avoid
that's part of life if you're telling a
story sometimes you're gonna include
something but you don't need to show it
graphically
there's no read that doesn't advance the
story there's no reason for it you do
that it's just it's just
attention-seeking
very clear that's what they're doing
here I only mention it because of that
one line from the from the creator of
the show saying well this is gonna this
is going to freak parents out I mean if
you have any if there's any confusion
about what Hollywood's goal is
especially when it comes to your kids or
how much respect they have for you as a
parent the answer is they have no
respect for you
the they've decided what sort of
material your child should be exposed to
and they're gonna go ahead and expose
your child to that and they don't care
if you as a parent are comfortable with
it this is yet again and I think in this
case especially because this is a show
apparently targeted to teenagers
specifically right so this is a show
that's very blatant about the fact that
it's trying to rip your kid away from
you and turn your kid into something
else something that you don't want your
kid to be Hollywood has a vision for
what sorts of people it wants to create
in this country and it's not gonna line
up with your vision for your kids so we
should never make any mistake about that
and as I have said many times I think
that there is well I'll put it this way
it would be very difficult to go too far
in my opinion in trying to shield your
kids from this kind of stuff I mean you
could go too far right and you've locked
your kid in a in a room for the first 18
years I literally have them in a bubble
like Bubble Boy that's probably going a
little too far but I think most of us as
parents aren't going nearly far enough
because you
at the age of 13 is exposed to this kind
of stuff and I'm not gonna say it's
gonna ruin his life forever or that the
damage is impossible to undo but it does
do real damage you know when we art I
mean I had I am loath to call this art
but it is technically an art form a
television show a story right so art has
the has a very profound impact on us and
anytime we're exposed to any kind of art
whether it's real art or quote-unquote
art there's a sort of process of
becoming we we change we become
something as we're changed by this thing
that we're exposed to or eat we're
either lift it up or we're dragged down
but it has a real effect on us and so
when your kids start ingesting stuff
like this it drags them down it starts
to change them and deform them and so
again it is very difficult to go too far
in trying to shield them from that for
instance saying okay I'm gonna drop off
the grid and go live in the woods right
with with with no internet no TV I think
that's not that's that's not too far at
all I think it's actually a great idea
I'm not doing it sometimes I think I
should I think that's a great idea if
you don't want to go that far then I
mean there are little things like don't
give your kid a phone with the internet
I mean that's see we look at a step like
that and we see that as all that's
extreme
I think that's radical what are you
talking about it no no internet for the
kid how is he gonna survive that's not
radical at all that's I think when you
consider just the filth the grotesque
disgusting mind-warping filth that is
out there and that Hollywood and other
forces are trying desperately to get in
front of your kids eyes when you
consider all of that something as simple
as not giving your kid a phone with the
Internet is a wreath at Stan to me
that's a base level step
all right um one other thing before we
get some emails Twitter user Briley is
her name she's just a just a Twitter
user I don't think this is a it's not
some media member or anything but she
sent out a tweet a couple days ago and
is now getting death threats for it of
course a lot of outrage death threats
everything else death wishes you know
I've been there myself and this happened
after she sent a completely normal and
in my opinion inoffensive tweet this is
what this this woman said she said call
me old-fashioned but I was raised to
take care of my husband make his plate
every night wash his work clothes for
him make sure he's up for work the next
morning always have a clean house for
him to come home to etc etc and that's
exactly the wife I will be okay so that
was the tweet and of course it's been
retweeted tens of thousands of times and
as I said all this outrage and people
are insulting her and with a wishing
wishing death even threatening Tesh
death on her because of this tweet which
is what's the offensive now of course I
know the moment I open to see that to he
before I even read the reactions I knew
how people would react to it I'm not
naive I'm not stupid I know that people
will see that as offensive but that's
just because we live in a very silly
very stupid culture in reality
objectively speaking there is nothing
offensive about this whatsoever
so she said as a white-shoe wife she
wants to make a plate of you know make
dinner for her husband while she's
clothes for him make sure he's up in the
morning have a clean house that's you
know what that is that's that's normal
that is the normal everyday sort of life
of a homemaker if somebody wants to be a
homemaker that's what you do you're
doing the laundry your your cooking
cooking food your taking care of your
family cleaning the house it is a
perfectly
I think wonderfully noble vocation maybe
it's not for everyone snob it's not what
every woman wants to do that's fine
but there are still women who have that
desire and it's perfectly Noble and it
involves all of these things there's
nothing wrong with that
the only thing that she listed that's
maybe arguably a step beyond just normal
homemaker kind of responsibilities is
where she says make sure he's up for
work in them in the morning okay well
you know I mean I think a good wife will
do that for her husband if he's sleeping
in needs to get out for work she'll help
bring it up right I think that's it
isn't that what a wife will do my wife
does it for me I didn't I didn't think
it was any big deal but of course
feminists are reacting to this and say
oh so it's hard internalized misogyny
and everything because number one what
we realize is that feminists are big
advocates for choice they want women to
make choices unless they choose
something quote-unquote old-fashioned
like this unless they choose it to be an
attentive you know sort of conservative
homemaker and wife and mother if that
choice is not acceptable any other
choice though I mean literally any other
choice you want to make with your life
if you want to go out and be a
prostitute I mean that they would
consider that to be a much more noble
vocation than what this woman has just
described and that of course is not an
exaggeration but in reality this is just
taking care of the family and I think
what you find is is a lot of people in
our society they just cannot accept that
there should be any element of service
in a marriage especially on the part of
the wife the idea that the wife would it
all serve her husband I think makes is
just as repulsive to modern people but
if that's the attitude you have I just
have to tell you this ahead of time to
save you the heartache and I tell you
this if you read that tweet and your
gutter lis repulsed by it and angered by
it then I tell you right now don't get
married because your marriage is gonna
be a failure your marriage will fail now
I'm not saying that you
to agree with everything in this tweet
and and you have your marriage has to be
exactly like that in order for to be
successful not saying that but if you
were just completely repulsed by this
notion by that by the very idea of a
woman you know making a meal for her
husband or doing the laundry but if that
if that whole idea is repulsive to you
it come is offensive to you then yes you
marriage is not for you you're gonna
your marriage will fail absolutely
because service is part of marriage
serving your spouse and yes the husband
serves the wife too but the wife also
serves the husband and if you're not on
board with that if you're not interested
in that then seriously do not get
married you will get divorced you you
have to be willing to serve your spouse
or it's just not gonna work because
that's what a marriage is that's what
makes it work you have the once
picking up the slack for the other in
this area and then the others you could
pick up the slack in another area and
it's a complementary nature that's how
marriages work it really isn't any other
way there isn't any other functional way
to do it
alright so I've just a just a warning
there for you let's go to emails Matt
well show at gmail.com Matt Walsh Oh at
gmail.com
this is from grace I believe it says
dear mr. Walsh I hope this finds you
well and that your ankle isn't playing
you isn't playing you up too much I'm
isn't playing you up too much is that
a-- okay so someone from the UK so that
must be a UK expression i'm writing from
the UK and the news is currently full of
controversy about a comedians joke about
throwing battery acid over nigel farage
she was a hilarious joke isn't it great
grades great wit there she's being
investigated by the police and left wing
commentators have been gloriously
proclaiming that the right are
snowflakes for being offended by the gag
i'm somewhat mixed over this i think
that you should be free to joke about
anything but i know that the reaction
would have been different had the target
of the joke than a left-wing figure and
it feels satisfying to see the left
suffering a taste of their own medicine
how can we reconcile this in the future
though it can't just be the case that
the right is always hounded out of a job
etc because of comments that are deemed
unacceptable yet the left continues to
get away with it but then it seems to me
that the free speech concerns are the
same no matter who is speaking and
pleasant as it is to see the left suffer
it can't be right to pursue the same
strategy should the right pursue and
censor people to send a message to the
left or will it only continue to respond
in part or is there another better way
to deal with to deal with this problem
I'd be very grateful for your advice
because the hypocrisy of my feelings
have been bothering me greatly
yeah grace a great question I struggle
with this myself on one hand I believe
in intellectual integrity and
consistency I preach it all the time so
if I advocate for free speech for
ourselves we have to advocate it for
others as well right if we want free
speech for ourselves we have to want it
for others as well that's called being
intellectually consistent on the other
hand I do perhaps in my weaker moments
see the logic in the argument that the
left should be hoisted with its own
petard and forced to live by its own
rules I do see the attraction to that
approach to the approach that says okay
forget about principles let's just make
these people taste their own medicine
for a change see how they like it
but that of course is just vengeance in
the end if we're going to be governed by
our minds rather than by our feelings
our emotions I think we have to stay
true to our principles because if we
don't then what's the point
so I think we have to say that yeah that
that joke is it's a stupid jokes a bad
joke it's an offensive joke it's a
witless joke but it it's not criminal or
it shouldn't be criminal and a person
should be free to make a joke like that
as bad as it is even though they're on
the left and so on and so forth
I think that has to be our position
because if it isn't if we take the other
approach then what's the point if we
become the left to beat the left then
hasn't the left already won haven't they
essentially converted us then to their
relativistic worldview haven't we become
nihilist just like them and thus the
game is lost I think that's the thing
that the Conservatives is our you know
throw it I forget about the principles
is your stupid print throw all that to
the side this is how the left operates
so shall we should operate let's play by
their rules
well yes but this fly is like there's a
fly or if you can see it on camera I
hope you could see the fly on camera
otherwise I'm just I've just been doing
this the whole show looking like I have
some sort of condition anyway where was
I oh yes if we abandon our principles
and just say okay let's let's you know
let's let's adopt the left's approach
well then we've become them then they've
won because they've they've created
exactly the kind of culture they wanted
to create where everybody has adopted
their philosophy their there their
principles
or lack thereof though the whole point
here is that we are trying to establish
a culture that is not relativistic that
is not nihilistic so if they're if they
are that way and then we become that way
then everybody is and they've won they
won so yes I agree with you that we I
think we need to maintain our principles
all right this is from Jack says Matt I
used to be a fan until I read your
scrambled egg recipe on Twitter this
morning I am horrified sour cream in
eggs you sir are a communist yeah this
is something we were talking about on
Twitter I was saying that most it's a
big problem in this country most people
don't know how to make scrambled eggs
and so if you if you go to a restaurant
I never ordered scrambled eggs at
restaurants anymore because of this
problem if you go to someone's house
they make you scramble eggs what it ends
up being is that what they're really
serving you is sort of burnt egg flakes
not scrambled eggs which are supposed to
be fluffy and delicious and delightful
most people don't know how to do it so I
shared that the the correct scrambled
eggs recipe which I will tell you now
this is how you make scrambled eggs okay
what you do is you you take you take you
crack the eggs into your pan you put
butter in with the raw eggs a generous
amount of butter you whip all the eggs
together with the butter you put the pan
on about medium heat you know medium low
about there there about your scrambling
the whole time right a little salt and
pepper in there and then when you're
about 20 seconds from being done you put
in a nice dollop of sour cream in the
sour cream is very poor I'm not even a
sour cream fan I don't really even like
sour cream but you need it in the eggs
because that's going to give it that
kind of fluff at the end that's going to
give it the fluffiness is the sour cream
at the end and that's how you make
scrambled eggs mistakes people make you
don't mix you don't mix milk into the
eggs you don't need milk you use butter
not milk
you don't put butter into the pan ahead
of time and then wait for it to heat up
and then throw the eggs and because then
you're going to overcook your eggs
they're gonna get burned
you do it that way if you start to smell
burnt eggs at any point in the in the
process of making the scramble eggs it's
finished done you've ruined it you've
ruined a breakfast you've ruined the
eggs you've ruined the day basically
you're a failure
throw the eggs out start over again the
moment you smell that burning smell it's
finished it's you can't recover from
that okay that's how you make scrambled
eggs in case you're wondering this flies
all right um this is from Roger says hi
Matt I'm a huge fan and getting to meet
you some days at tops on my bucket list
well you need to get better items on
your bucket list trust me it's not that
thrilling to meet me in the meantime an
email will suffice I'm a police officer
that finds myself listening to your
shows often while on duty
has helped me pass many long shifts my
dilemma is in regards to newly found
faith in Jesus Christ I was a vehement
atheist up until a few years ago when a
suicide attempt led to me accepting the
Lord and last-ditch effort to salvage
what I felt was a wasted life since then
my life has taken a complete u-turn I
found meaning in both my personal life
as well as my career and I've striven
striving to be the best Christian I
could be in doing so I've found myself
prioritizing both the lives of the born
and the unborn as someone who was once a
strong pro-choice believer I now realize
the modern-day atrocities of abortion
her selfless efforts have really helped
me lately that leads to me to the
dilemma in question the church I found
myself attending is very soft when it
comes to the lives of the unborn
I had a long discussion with one of the
leaders of the church who essentially
told me that he believes there are
scriptural reasons to believe that human
life does not begin until outside of the
womb it's completely false the notion
that the geographical location of an
8-month fetus which would have survived
prematurely seems antithetical of the
Scriptures I've read I've also spoken
with other fellow members of the church
who have expressed gratitude that the
church doesn't speak out against
abortion what is your recommendation for
a single Christian who is still finding
his way in his own faith do you think
I'm overstepping my boundaries if I
schedule a meeting with the pastor to
express my concern while it seems many
churches are becoming more progressive
do you think churches should
make the abortion should make abortion
the abortion issue a priority from the
pulpit another one of my friends was in
the was the first to invite me to the
church when I was an atheist told me
that for tax-exempt purposes it's a good
thing that it stays away from the pulpit
thanks for all you've done in my life
over the past year alone in moulding
some of my strongest viewpoints even
though I'm only in my early 20s I feel
like people like you have helped pioneer
my faith both today and in the future I
had god bless well Roger thanks for the
for that email thanks for sharing your
story thank you for having the courage
to turn your life around to make a
change thank you for not giving up on
life and on yourself thank you for all
that as to your question you are not at
all overstepping by advocating for the
unborn at your church I think you should
absolutely keep doing that absolutely
continue down that road I would also as
a cautionary note say that after you
talk to the pastor if you find that the
church is just steadfastly well
certainly if it's if it's if it is if
you find that it is a pro-abortion
Church or a church that is absolutely
determined to be neutral on the subject
then I would say maybe consider finding
a new church and I know that's kind of
easy for me to say this is the church
that you your friend brought you into
it's the only church you know or have
known but you know there are there are
bad churches out there not not all
churches are made equal and if this is a
church where the leadership believes
that it's okay to kill babies then I
think it's a bad Church it's a great
step you made in going to church don't
get me wrong but for your faith to
progress and mature and to you know and
to continue to grow as we all need our
faith to you know in our own lives for
our faith to grow it's possible that
case you need to find another church but
I think talking to the pastor is a good
good step and just see how that
conversation go
I think it's a great great idea I do
think that defending the unborn should
be a priority of every church this is a
number one issue that we face in our
culture it's the number one cultural
injustice and churches all churches
should be engaged in the fight they
should not take a back seat I don't
think any church has the right
I don't think any Church has the moral
right to take a back seat or to try to
be neutral that's my opinion
this is from John says Matt I have heard
many Christians say if there's something
you desire speak it into existence
whenever I hear this said I feel like it
portrays God as a genie who will grant
every wish if we believe we just believe
enough I understand how this can be an
exercise of faith but I think Christians
view faith as a trade if we have faith
we'll get something in return I was
diagnosed with kidney disease two years
ago when I was just twenty I had faith
that God would cure me but I also had
faith that there was a purpose for this
obstacle and that God would give me
strength to get through it instead of
speaking my will into existence I think
we should speak God's will what are your
thoughts on this also did Adam and Eve
have belly buttons well in that last
question I'm gonna say yes just because
the idea of people without belly buttons
freaks me out
as for speaking things into existence I
agree we don't have that ability we are
not God God spoke the world into
existence God speaks things into
existence we don't do that our positive
thoughts will not of themselves cause
good things to happen it doesn't work
that way and I really I really hate that
cliche but I'll you know keep a positive
attitude and you know if you if you if
you if you think it will have that it
will happen all that kind of stuff
it's there's so many problems with it
let's just start with the I mean think
about all the horrible things that
happen in this world think about the
worst kinds of the good thing about
parent whose child is dying of cancer
there are many parents in the world who
are in that position right now are we
gonna tell them to just think positive
and speak it into existence speak a cure
into existence we're gonna tell them
that positive thoughts will will change
everything and you know just just just
have a good attitude it's absurd and
it's grotesque
the fact is in this life horrible
horrible horrible things can and do
happen regardless of how positive you
are
regardless of your optimistic attitude
regardless of anything it's just the
reality and platitudes and cliches are
not going to change that and they don't
help when someone is in that position
you know I think sometimes we have to
start by it just when someone is in a
horrible position or dealing with
something that is horrible
we have to start by acknowledging like
yes this is unspeakably awful and and
there might not be anything you can do
to change it which is one of the things
that makes it so unspeakably awful but
that doesn't mean that it's hopeless I
think that once we accept that reality
once we accept that we are helpless in a
position in a situation once we accept
that horrible things can and do happen
and will happen to us personally at some
point you know at some point your life a
really horrible thing is gonna happen to
probably more than once a really
horrible thing will happen once we start
by acknowledging that then we can begin
to rely on God rather than on our own
mindset and submit ourselves to his will
rather than trying to somehow change the
unchangeable through our own will so
that's a long way of saying I agree with
everything that you said in your email
thank you for that and thanks everybody
for watching and listening have a great
weekend Godspeed today on the Ben
Shapiro show Iran gets militants and the
press blame Trump that's today on the
bench Shapiro show